[Musique]
bonsoir nous sommes le 24 novembre 2016
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition de
votre journal d'information locale voici
sans plus attendre les titres elle les
élections à la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie suite et fin dans les
yvelines gérard bacheliers et retrouve
son poste pour un la deuxième mandat
patrimoine avec l'un à toile de jouy
désormais en vente en ligne un hit shop
a été lancée afin d'exporter au mieux
cette marque du patrimoine national et
puis musique avec le rappeur black m
présenté hier aux clayes-sous-bois pour
une séance de dédicaces plus de 500 fans
l'attendaient pour l'occasion élections
hier soir du président de la cci
versailles yvelines la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie a donc reconduit
à sa tête gérard bacheliers le chef
d'entreprise entame son deuxième mandat
alors du scrutin sa liste soutenue par
la cgpme a recueilli 21 une voix contre
9 pour celles appuyé notamment par le
medef la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie dont la mission est
d'accompagner les entreprises a
néanmoins eu du mal à mobiliser ses
électeurs moins de 7% des patrons du
département car ce sont eux qui votent
se sont exprimés écoutez à ce sujet
gérard bacheliers il revient également
sur les difficultés de financement que
rencontrent sa structure les chefs
d'entreprise ne sont pas là pour nous
soutenir suffisamment et on espère que
dans nos actions ils vont nous soutenir
un petit peu plus les moyens on a pu
suffisamment effectivement c'est à dire
que dans notre chambre départementale
on a une réduction des effectifs de
moitié
ce qui est très important donc on manque
de moyens la chambre régionale manque de
moyens on manque de moyens pour les
écoles et les écoles c'est important il
ya quand même trente mille étudiants
dans les aidant les 24 écoles de la
chambre quinze mille apprentis tant que
sans les moyens pour justement gérer ces
écoles leur permettent d'investir dans
de nouveaux matériels je pense que ça
aura des effets effectivement sur
l'apprentissage
entretien complet avec le président de
la cci à suivre la semaine prochaine sur
notre antenne et concernant les
difficultés financières la situation ne
devrait pas s'améliorer à l'échelle
paris ile de france le projet de loi
finances 2017 prévoit une baisse de 14
millions d'euros ld taxe reversée à
l'organisme les premiers migrants sont
arrivés sur le site de l'inria arts au
concours d'autres devraient à venir
d'ici à demain vendredi une trentaine
d'hommes âgés d'une vingtaine et d'une
trentaine d'années originaire d'afrique
mais évacués de paris sont dorénavant
hébergés ici impossible d'accéder à ce
lieu placé sous surveillance leur prise
en charge est assurée par la croix rouge
jusqu'au 31 à décembre selon les
informations qui circulent actuellement
tout autre sujet à présent les 26 et 27
novembre se tiendra la fête culinaire
des gourmands des gastronomes consacré
aux produits et aux métiers de bouche
aux quatre coins du département des
yvelines les passionnés apprentis
amateurs curieux et bien sûr les
producteurs locaux et les chefs vont se
retrouver aussi autour de différents
ateliers
le chef italien simeone and honey et
cette année le parrain de cet événement
le reportage pour le conseil
départemental des yvelines de maxime le
mène
19 heures c'est le coup de feu au
domaine de madame elisabeth à versailles
ce soir le conseil départemental lance
la 4ème édition de good yvelines
l'opération met à l'honneur des
producteurs locaux et des chefs qui
anime pendant deux week-ends des
ateliers aux quatre coins du département
c'est un coup de projecteur alors on est
là pour être partenaire pour être
facilitateur et pour être dans une dans
une énergie de développement au niveau
économique parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est ça
que nos partenaires attendent de nous si
qu'on les accompagne pour qu'ils
puissent embaucher travailler et se
développer des partenaires comme hélène
bergouignan ozeki chef à domicile
spécialisé dans la cuisine fusion ce
soir à la con côté des recettes
japonaise avec des légumes des yvelines
je pense que c'est important de faire
connaître des producteurs locaux
j'achète mes produits chez un maraîcher
qui produit à aubergenville donc on dans
le 78 mon poissonnier et sur le marché
de poissy mon boucher et à poissy
également good yvelines c'est également
une façon d'allier gastronomie et
tourisme comme le rappelle le parrain de
l'opération le chef simone zanoni qui a
longtemps officié au trianon palace à
versailles
aujourd'hui à cette forte volonté dé
faire connaître des lieux comme les
domaines et délit d'aidé madame
elisabeth qui est inconnu pour la
plupart même dé versailles et on a
vraiment envie de faire sortir les gens
faire connaître les petits les petites
pépites qu'ils ont juste à côté de chez
eux parce que en a forcément là pas la
tendance des aléas visiter des endroits
comme ça en solo en famille ou entre
amis venez découvrir ce week-end le
savoir-faire de ceux qui font la
gastronomie yvelinoise retrouvez le
programme complet sur good yvelines
point fr
gastronomie toujours avec le week-end
dernier à mort par la quatrième édition
du salon des vins des saveurs et des
couleurs l'occasion une nouvelle fois
pour les saint quentinois est de
découvrir la richesse des produits de
notre terroir haussmann vendeurs des et
patrick jacques de dixmude
une cinquantaine d'exposants venus des
quatre coins de la france ont répondu
présent pour le salon des vins des
couleurs et des saveurs qui s'est
déroulé à maurepas pour david de soligny
producteurs de foie gras il est
important d'être sur place on représente
un peu la gastronomie française c'est
l'époque des fêtes il faut nous faire
connaître au niveau des produits locaux
du terroir
il sera peu oublié certaines fois donc
on se présente directement au
consommateur premier but de l'événement
la découverte des produits du terroir
mais ce salon a aussi un aspect
caritatif les fonds qui sont récoltées
sont versés intégralement aux oeuvres
sociales de notre club nous vous aidons
2 certaines associations de maurepas
nos repas entraide qui s'occupe pour
l'illettrisme mort pas vivre debout
s'occupe des pour des handicapés nous
faisons partie en voyage des enfants de
maurepas qui n'ont pas le bonheur de
partir en vacances et leur offrant une
journée dans un parc d'attractions
l'événement a rassemblé plus de 500
visiteurs
nous vous proposons à présent un
portrait direction villepreux où se
trouve peut-être la future star du monde
du maquillage l'yvelinois aspirine
allouche étudiante au lycée florian aso
a été élu meilleur apprenti de france
devant un jury de professionnels le
reportage est signé mais quel ennemi
d'euros
trop bien à première vue perrine
allouche est une étudiante comme les
autres mais cette ville proviennent de
17 ans a créé la sensation dans le monde
du maquillage en devenant meilleur
apprenti de france en octobre dernier
avec son dessin sur le thème du dragon
chinois elle a véritablement enflammé le
jury une grande émotion pour la jeune
fille repenser tout ce qu'on a travaillé
les pantoufles pour les mois où on s'est
entraîné avec mon professeur modèle même
une autre fille de ma classe qui a aussi
parcouru est comme moi le concours du
coup d'en repenser à tout ça et on dit
que maintenant on arrivé là et du coup
ça fait bizarre vous aimez le court ici
pourtant c'est yvelinoise n'est pas né
avec cette passion dans la peau le
maquillage et commencé quand je suis
rentré en seconde au lycée avant je
m'intéressais pas tellement c'était
plutôt les ongles que je faisais et
c'est après avec les cours ça m'a donné
encore plus envie de le faire et le
concours du coup ça ça m'a vraiment
donné encore plus envie de
avant d'arriver au strass et aux
paillettes d'un titre de meilleur
apprenti perrine allouche a répété ses
gammes dans cette salle de classe du
lycée des métiers florian aso c'est ici
que j'ai été formé c'est ici qu'on
faisait les entraînements donc elle ma
professeur madame st martin donc c'est
ici que tout a commencé en fait dans la
structure la ville proviennent a pu
bénéficier des conseils de son
enseignante miley saint-martin meilleur
ouvrier de france en 2015 dans la
section esthétique art du maquillage
pour elle le succès de sa protégée ne
fait aucun doute elle est minutieuse
danse dans ce qu'elle fait et en
esthétique il et il faut cette qualité
là et elle est toujours
agréable en cours et voilà le travail
très bien des qualités qui pourraient
comme dans ses rêves les plus fous l'a
propulsé comme maquilleuse sur des
défilés français et internationaux dans
les années à venir j'ai beaucoup
d'objectifs en fait je vais pas faire
qu'une chose dans ma vie je sais que
j'ai envie de travailler en maquillage
de scène maquillage artistique
pourquoi pas être professeur aussi mais
avant de penser à l'avenir perrine devra
obtenir son bac pro en juin prochain un
examen moins glamour qu'un titre
d'apprentis mais qui lui ouvrira les
portes du monde du travail
culture et patrimoine avec la toile de
jouer qui trois siècles après à sa
création continue de séduire le public
du monde entier cette étoffe de coton
qui trouve ses origines dans les
yvelines à jouy en josas peut dorénavant
être achetés en ligne à un heat shock
vient d'ouvrir ses portes
la toile de jouy entre dans une nouvelle
ère eric langlois jova sien depuis 15
ans a décidé de lancer en janvier
dernier un hip hop sur ce thème on y
retrouve des coussins des plateaux des
torchons des chaussons inspiré des
célèbres motif de bach comme feu datant
du xviiie siècle je suis un passionné
d'art décoratif je connais le musée j'ai
visité la boutique j'ai apprécié
énormément tous les produits qu'on y
trouvait le luciste tout simplement dit
que pour moi internet représentait une
opportunité formidable de faire
connaître
toute cette richesse patrimoniale au
plus grand nombre une passion soutenu
par le musée de la toile de jouy la
structure a signé un partenariat avec
l'entrepreneur pour commercialiser les
mêmes produits dans sa boutique et sur
le site internet c'est quelque chose
qu'on attendait avec impatience parce
que c'est vrai qu'on a la boutique au
musée mais de nombreuses personnes qui
suivent notre page facebook ou ou des
gens qui sont venus pire partie nous
demander mais est-ce qu est-ce qu on
peut trouver des objets de la boutique
en dehors de la boutique du musée le
eshop compte à ce jour deux mille
visites par mois avec un panier moyen de
50 euros pour rendre les produits encore
plus attractif éric lenglos à travailler
avec des blogueuses l'idée est de
moderniser les motifs il faut à la fois
faire des produits qui sont des
classiques mais il faut aussi revisiter
le classicisme en ajoutant des touches
modernes par exemple ce qui se fait
beaucoup c'est d'ajouter une touche fluo
dans un objet de décoration par exemple
mais on est en train par exemple
actuellement de créer
des nouveaux produits des coussins et
des foulards à partir de motifs
historiques inédits prochain objectif
eric langlois espère développer les
exportations à travers la france et
pourquoi pas dépasser les frontières de
l'hexagone pour atteindre le public
asiatique
c'est l'un des chanteurs français du
moment le rappeur black m qui a débuté
sa carrière avec le groupe sexion
d'assaut était à cultura du côté des
clayes-sous-bois dans ce magasin dédié
aux produits culturels c'était mercredi
après midi l'artiste aux 600 mille
albums écoulés dans l'hexagone en 2015
auteur de différents tubes notamment sur
ma route s'est prêté au jeu des
dédicaces vous le voyez et des photos
avec plus de 500 fans qui étaient
présents qui se sont bousculés pour
l'occasion et c'est notre journaliste
people michael et demi d'euros qui a
rencontré ses fans je vois devant mon
écran mon club de voir en vrai
c'est bien oui et déjà un album allait
très bien mais merde mais mon père et ma
mère il n patron je rougis d'un coup
j'ai demandé un autographe
pour meilleure amie et moi je crois que
je vais encadrer dans ma chambre et j'ai
donné demain à l'école
mon meilleur ami
il est mignon
c'est sympa mais j'aime bien avec
l'équipe des petites filles peut être
que fan il séduit toutes les générations
c'est la fin de ce journal en tout cas
rendez vous elle lundi pour une nouvelle
édition consacrée en grande partie aux
résultats de la primaire de la droite et
du centre demain vendredi vous avez
rendez vous avec nikola kirillovitch
pour un nouveau l 7,8 hebdo avec son
invité et ils reviendront sur
l'essentiel de l'actualité elle de la
semaine en attendant les programmes se
poursuivent bien sûr sur notre antenne
[Musique]